digamos que tenemos a dos personas que
tienen trabajos idénticos tenemos a la
persona y a la persona vez y el año
pasado ambos recibieron como pago en su
trabajo idéntico trescientos cincuenta
mil dólares cada uno ahora vamos a
asumir que la persona no tiene ninguna
deducción así que calcularon sus
impuestos y para hacerlo sencillo voy a
inventar un número no voy a tomar una
deducción real de impuestos porque estos
luego son variables año con año digamos
que los impuestos regulares son de 150
mil dólares escribimos aquí en 150 mil
dólares en impuestos regulares impuestos
regulares
ahora digamos que la persona ve que
tiene exactamente el mismo trabajo y
gana exactamente lo mismo ha donado
mucho a la caridad y tiene muchas
deducciones y otras cosas que se pueden
eliminar de sus entradas así que la
persona ve tiene una entrada gravable
que se reduce con todas las deducciones
que tiene llega a una cantidad de 200
mil dólares y toda esta entrada gravable
de 200 mil dólares la persona ve tiene
que pagar 70 mil dólares en impuestos
regulares y nuevamente estoy inventando
números para simplificar esto no estoy
calculando impuestos reales a partir de
estas cantidades en impuestos regulares
70 mil ahora la oficina de impuestos de
los eeuu pueden decir bueno esta persona
ve ganó bastante dinero una cantidad
similar a la persona a tuvo todas estas
deducciones que le permitieron pagar
muchos menos impuestos regulares esto no
nos agrada y creemos que debe de pagar
al menos un impuesto mínimo alternativo
y la forma en que esto se calcula es que
para cualquiera de los dos empleados hay
un código completamente separado de
impuestos impuesto mínimo alternativo
así pues se calcula de los impuestos
regulares que es este número y este otro
número y en paralelo se calcula el
impuesto mínimo alternativo y en el caso
de cualquiera de estas dos personas lo
que sucede es que no se obtienen todas
estas deducciones se hace por cuestiones
de simplicidad con respecto a la entrada
principal
y es un código de impuestos mucho más
simple en el nivel de los 350 mil
dólares no se tiene ninguna deducción
estándar y es el 26 por ciento
dentro de los primeros 175 mil
es 28 por ciento en los siguientes 175
mil y si ustedes ganando esta cantidad
de dinero si tienen alguna deducción
pueden tener menos que esto pero no
entraré en detalles la idea general es
que pueden calcular es para cualquiera
de las dos personas y en ambas
situaciones el impuesto mínimo
alternativo para cualquiera de las dos
personas será 94 mil 500 dólares
así que en el caso de la persona su
impuesto mínimo alternativo es del 94
mil 500 y su impuesto lo regular es de
150 mil por lo que va a pagar el más
alto de los dos va a pagar 150 mil
dólares
por otra parte la persona ve vemos que
esos impuestos regulares después de
todas las deducciones son de 70 mil
dólares por lo que él tiene que pagar el
impuesto mínimo alternativo de 94.500
que es el mayor de ambos impuestos así
que esto es lo que él tiene que pagar
así pues la idea general es que se
calculan los impuestos regulares el
impuesto mínimo alternativo y se va a
pagar el mayor de estos dos la idea de
esto es asegurarse que las personas que
tienen cierto sueldo no reduzcan todo y
paguen un impuesto muy muy pequeño